[Música]
buenos días
a pesar de haber crecido en la ciudad de
mexico donde los monstruitos la ciudad
mayor
tuviera oportunidades muchísimo al campo
crecida del corazón en la zona en la
zona bomba en la fase de la ciudad pero
misma para construir puentes en las
carreteras y así es que pase todas las
vacaciones desde muy chico en zonas
rurales en zonas exploradas y tuve ese
contacto con la naturaleza que me llevó
a pensar que lo que yo quería hacer era
estudiar la vida que otra carrera podría
darme más que estudiar la vida en un
planeta es donde esta vida es el
fenómeno más extraordinario estudió
biología después me interesó la
tecnología pero en méxico en esa época
no había cosas y es que decidí irme a
canadá a estudiar con uno de los mejores
psicólogos del mundo fue todo una
travesía llegar a canadá que no sabía yo
inglés para comenzar
habrá financiamiento necesitaba una
serie de cosas y un día apareció en
vancouver en una ciudad muy bonita
pero aparecía y sin visa de estudiante
sin saber injerencia y sin dinero para
mantenerme
hace seis meses difíciles pero valieron
la pena
y valieron la pena porque mi asesor me
invitó a trabajar a un paraíso este
paraíso es el parque nacional pln y en
el cerca del círculo polar ártico y en
este paraíso del tamaño del estado de
méxico en donde hay animales que nunca
han visto a un ser humano y menos a un
mexicano en la base todos los días
sabiendo a las 8 de la mañana del
campamento yendo a esas montañas que sea
ese glaciar que está ahí atrapar
animales mi especialidad es atrapar
animales vivos marcarlos pesarlos
estudiarlos soltamos y ver sus
poblaciones yo trabajé con animales
pequeñitos con ratones con liebres pero
realmente los encuentros con estos otros
animales con el lobo gris el cual está
en la situación precaria en nuestro país
con el lince canadiense el cual tiene un
pariente aquí en méxico aquí cerquita
linces mexicanos
montes
y el oso grizzly que desapareció méxico
en los años 50
realmente era lo que le ponía el sabor a
la investigación unos días estaban solo
10 12 horas en esta época de marzo a
septiembre en el jocón hay 20 horas de
día 4 de noche yo llegaba en marzo
cuando estaba quitando la nieve les
congelarán los lagos en junio y me
regresaba a vancouver en septiembre de
una experiencia de tres años el cerezo
que me llevó al encuentro si les
platicaré el primer encuentro que tuve
con un oso gris
salí por la mañana caminando a tener una
hora de camino para llegar
a la emisora de trabajo y en el camino
de las veredas empecé a escuchar un
ruido pero un ruido muy ligerito
seguramente se le dije es una una sola
roja son preciosas y la quise ver me
acerqué rápidamente y se me pasó a una
distancia de 45 metros unos un oso de
500 kilos de peso se levantó empezó a
patear ve a verme no tienen muy buena
vista
yo tenía todo un protocolo para estas
ocasiones sabía lo que tengo que hacer
vamos a encontrarnos
el oso me vio me miró a los ojos nos
quedamos viendo bajo mexicano
este tipo de encuentros que les
llevábamos desde entonces los encuentros
cercanos del tercer tipo de colores
desde muy joven
pero me acerco muchísimo a las especies
animales me hizo querer por ser más de
ellas estudiarlas saber su conducta su
ecología
después con el tiempo regresé a méxico a
trabajar trabajo en otro paraíso que
está la común esta reserva de la
biosfera y en calakmul estudiará más
estudia y vegetación estudia cacería de
subsistencia pero ahí me encuentro con
un personaje que era un chiclero que un
día me invita a
y para mí era una oportunidad nunca
había visto a alguien extraer el chicle
de un árbol me fui con él y en la noche
platicando en la fogata me preguntó qué
significó a día licaones quién de
ustedes sabe lo que ha significado no se
preocupe pero me sorprendía que una
persona sin educación supiera lo que era
un licuado y eso me dijo que tenía un
interés y no tenía fuentes de
información cómo hacer que esta gente
que está interesada pueda aprender sobre
la fauna de méxico vivimos en un país
una riqueza excepcional la mayor
diversidad de especies diversidad
especies endémicas diversidad de
ecosistemas centro de origen y
domesticación de muchas plantas de las
cuales nos alimentamos y sin embargo no
las conocemos la mayoría de las personas
no tenemos estructura de la naturaleza
cómo hacer que estos problemas que son
los cinco jinetes
lips is los cinco que están acabando con
nuestra naturaleza en la transformación
de hábitat la sobreexplotación la
introducción de especies exóticas y la
contaminación más ahora el cambio
climático este ponemos podamos
reducirlos
estas cinco factores no están alejados
son parte de nuestra vida diaria están
en el consumo de carne está en el
consumo de pescado está en el consumo de
vegetales que son crecidos con
fertilizantes insecticidas y nuestras
decisiones se vuelven muy importantes
aún como urbanitas tres veces al día
estamos consumiendo alimentos que tienen
un impacto en la naturaleza por la
cantidad de fertilizantes insecticidas y
no se diga la cuestión de la carne que
ya escucharemos más adelante
el principal problema desde mi punto de
vista es la falta de conocimiento es la
falta de encontrarnos con oso grizzly
que nos dejó ojos es la indiferencia
como hacer cómo cambiar esto en una
sociedad que cada vez es más urbanita
ese es el desafío y esa es la pregunta
como nación elevar todos los días cómo
acercar a la naturaleza y principalmente
la naturaleza mexicana a los mexicanos
no conocemos el tesoro que tenemos y que
estamos deteriorando día con día
como conectamos es la pregunta
en el trabajo después de dejarme hacer
investigación convencido de lo que tenía
que llevar era comunicar la problemática
ambiental me he dedicado a producir
materiales de todo tipo para josh en
lenguas indígenas libros sitios web
vídeos para acercar a la gente a la
naturaleza pero llegó el momento que
todo era internet y cómo hacer que la
gente nos separemos de internet pues a
través de una red social se llama
naturalista naturalista a semejanza de
la naturaleza donde tomas una foto tiene
identificación automática pero la red
social de 700.000 personas en el mundo
te ayuda a identificar a las especies
hoy mismo ustedes descargar la
aplicación y pueden empezar no solo a
conocer la naturaleza de méxico sino a
contribuir a su conocimiento cada una de
sus fotos es identificada forma parte de
un mapa y ustedes pueden conocer la
distribución de las especies insectos
plantas
los animales en este caso son 1.800
especies documentadas en la ciudad de
mexico
cuantas conocemos la transparencia forma
que iniciaba el cato mixto es una de las
especies que viven aquí con nosotros y
la mayoría los desconocemos
naturalista nos ha ayudado a identificar
la ruta de migración de la mariposa
monarca un abajo que ningún investigador
podría haber hecho sólo cuatro años
tenemos los sitios de pernocta en la
ruta gracias a la participación
ciudadana gracias a que la gente está en
lugar de tomar sin hacer te está
volteando la camarita y observando la
naturaleza ojalá podamos dejar de
tomarnos el fis y tomar best service a
la naturaleza
hemos hecho una cosa más en la dirección
de comunicación que es desarrollar una
plataforma que se llama enciclopedia si
no puede colaborar pueden consultar este
sitio en este sitio es fantástico es un
gran parásito que las páginas web las
jaulas con información de doctorados y
fans acepten a mil especies mexicanas
ustedes escriben el nombre lo pueden
escribir en ambato en maya zapoteco en
inglés y les va a fundar fotos vídeos
descripciones mapas registros no solo
científicos sino registros ciudadanos y
los registros ciudadanos se están
volviendo cada día más importantes el 60
por ciento de los registros a nivel
internacional son de gente como usted
que no necesariamente son investigadores
pero que quieren anticipar y conocer un
poquito más a la naturaleza para
terminar me gusta mucho esta frase de
radio que es
vega indicó que conservaremos solamente
lo que amamos amaremos lo que hacemos y
conocemos lo que nos es enseñado en su
época no será enseñado actualmente nos
enseñamos podemos enseñarnos a nosotros
mismos y con estas herramientas de cien
ciudadanos cualquiera de ustedes puede
aprender y conocer mucho más de lo que
yo conozco les recomiendo básicamente
que les dediquen un poquito de tiempo a
la naturaleza cinco minutos al día
conozcan a su vecino verde al árbol más
cercano al antes de pisar a la araña
tomé una foto por favor
a todos los alrededores dediquen el
tiempo de observar es con esa mirada a
los ojos de la naturaleza que vamos a
empezar a conocerla a valorarla a
respetarla y a mantener por razones
espirituales y no hay es la naturaleza
tiene que estar aquí nosotros llegamos
mucho después y somos los que tenemos
esa visión esa responsabilidad de no
sólo mantener la restaurarla y convenir
por media
hay también pueden empezar por su casa
utilicen estas plataformas por favor
difundan las pláticas sobre ellas porque
nunca antes habíamos tenido a la
naturaleza tan cerca en nuestro celular
y alguien disfrutando el conocimiento se
van a dar cuenta que vaya creciendo en
ustedes es una época muy buena para que
saquen al biólogo que tienen dentro y
salga del closet es muy buena
oportunidad utilizando estos
instrumentos van a disfrutar y van a
tener mucho más valoración por la
naturaleza que nos rodea muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]